hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wie heute zu einem neuen wie
die rallye im kalender konkret ist schon
ok heute ist der zehnte zehnte
wahrscheinlich nicht 15 sondern
irgendwann später das heißt diese kissen
sind jetzt gerade online in dem diese so
bequem ende
das hab ich noch ganz gut sagen und
jetzt gehts los mit dem video
ich habe euch wieder bei twitter gesagt
wir sollten irgendwelche videos zu
senden und das habt ihr wieder zahlreich
getan deswegen fahren wir direkt an hier
mit der ersten sendung korrekte aktion
liga finde ich richtig cool dafür direkt
mit sowas motivierende man familien
könnte es ganz einfach mal rückwärts
abspielen
[Applaus]
ok freunde erwachten zaubertrick
weder die münze ist noch immer da
das war nicht krass trotzt irgendein
tesafilm dings auf der rückseite eines
titels und hass denen die münze geklebt
das kein zaubertrick schon wieder für
eine scheiße alter equity mir einen
typus in sonder app der irgendwie auch
wenn andere typen hinz leide danke dass
ihr euch die mühe gemacht habt mir so
was machen aber es kam wirklich nicht
nur einmal an seinen video
die ganzen stars schenkte mir sowas 1
[Musik]
heraus ich bin raus muss ich doch
irgendwas dazu sagen ich war zwar nach
du hast hier nicht wirklich die mühe
gemacht und einen traum satz tomatensaft
und apfelsaft nebeneinandergestellt die
gegenseitig einander abgeworfen und dann
raus gefundenes traubensaft der stärkste
ist heute vielleicht solltet ihr mal
einfach irgendwie euch ein hobby
anschaffen wirklich überhaupt nichts
gegen euch ich bin die einsendung in
ultra cool aber hey das ist doch eher so
ist es auch cool wenn mal eine sendung
kommen würden wie ihr fußball spielt
oder wie ihr golf spielt oder wie ihr
irgendwie mir fragen gestellt oder so
zerfetzen kommt wirklich der elefant
münchen unterdessen ist da wirklich
jemand im garten und wie apfelsaft mit
traubensaft und tomatensaft ab ich meine
schätze ich mal vor ihre mutter gucke
dabei alles klar egal also hier
motiviert mich jeden tag aufs neue
videos raus sagt danke nur durch euch
bin ich der mensch geworden der ich bin
am 19
diese folge heute geht wirklich komplett
weg school wir hatten tomaten sagte
werth nach für satz drin hatten die
trauben sind obwohl er doch irgendwie
von mir erwähnt wurde und jetzt hat es
da noch ein video 1 gesendet wo er
irgendein neues wort sei das heißt wir
schauen uns an was er uns diesmal
mitzuteilen hat gemälde kamillentee
alles klar als klar als glatt bin
eigentlich ein riesiger tv wilden tier
habe ich noch nie richtig gemocht also
ich trink wirklich unglaublich viel
orange ingwer tee pfefferminztee
unglaublich viel auch immer wenn ich mit
max ums apple irgendwo bin aber von
kamillentee weiß ich selbst noch nie der
fall und ich sehe auch ehrlich gesagt
selten leute die kamellen tätig
da haben wir schon im ersten kabinett ev
ich sehe jetzt schon dass kamillentee
das neue tomatensaft ist neuer apfelsaft
neue was hatten wir dann noch alles das
soll ein neuer trend hier wieder wird
unter meinen videos und ich versuche das
wesentliche nächster zeit häufiger zu
machen dass ich eure videos kommt ihre
weil ich sehr einfach das so kraft
ankommt was likes dislike verhältnisse
angeht es macht einfach spaß und ich
meine ich habe euch als community drin
wir entwickeln uns eigenen insider und
ich werde schon wieder total
melancholisch hier wenn heute das video
gefallen hat zeigte mit dem daumen nach
oben soll ich mehr von so was machen
kommentiert komitee ja diese kitzen hier
vorne gibt es ab heute im weissen gas
ist und immer aber die schwarzen sind
heute noch dazu gekommen und ich finde
sogar noch lauter als die weise obwohl
es eigentlich genau die gleichen kissen
sind aber irgendwie keine ahnung
hier findet ihr einen smiley
eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf den könnt
ihm einen kanal abonnieren wäre mega
chillig weil ich dann halt neuen aber du
bist teil der familie hier von uns und
hier findet ihr das letzte video
eingeblendet wo ich euch eure
ein video kommentiert habe sheikh dieser
art